en este vídeo quiero exploremos la idea
de lo que es un vector unitario y
déjenme apuntarlo aquí quiero explorar
la idea de un vector vector unitario
unitario vector unitario ok y un vector
unitario no es ni más ni menos que un
vector que va hacia una dirección y que
tiene una magnitud de 1 lo voy a
escribir tiene una magnitud de 1 una
magnitud de 1 y es más vamos a verlo con
un ejemplo imagínate que yo me tomo al
vector a este va a ser director am y
tiene como coordenadas vamos a abrir
paréntesis y le voy a poner las
coordenadas 3 4 así que déjame
escribirlo y tiene como coordenadas
entonces voy a poner justo aquí un 3 y
después voy a poner un 4 con este color
si yo te pregunto cuál es la longitud o
la magnitud de este vector como lo
puedes obtener y vamos a ponerlo así la
magnitud de este vector a yo lo que voy
a buscar es la magnitud de este vector a
que por cierto no es otra cosa más que
la longitud de este vector al vamos a
visualizarlo por aquí a la derecha y es
que de una manera horizontal
yo voy a caminar tres unidades de una
manera horizontal voy a caminar tres
unidades estas son tres unidades y
después de una manera vertical hacia
arriba voy a caminar cuatro unidades así
que déjame ponerlo así por cada tres
unidades que yo me mueva hacia la
derecha voy a caminar cuatro unidades
hacia arriba y entonces mi vector se va
a ver más o menos así es un vector que
va a empezar aquí y entonces va a subir
hasta acá es este vector de aquí
este sería mi vector a mi vector a ok y
bueno entonces cuál es la magnitud de
este vector
te das cuenta no es más que otra cosa
que tomarnos un teorema de pitágoras
esta es muy poderosa y aquí tengo mis
otros dos lados de este triángulo
rectángulo y por lo tanto puedo decir
que el vector av
tiene como magnitud que por cierto
recuerda que es la longitud de este
vector bueno pues la raíz cuadrada ok de
cada una de sus dos componentes elevadas
al cuadrado es decir me va a quedar 3
elevado al cuadrado 3 elevado al
cuadrado ya esto tengo que sumarle la
otra componente que es 4 elevado al
cuadrado así que déjame ponerlo así 4
elevado al cuadrado y si te das cuenta
esto es lo mismo que tomar de la raíz
cuadrada de 9 16 lo cual es 25 y bueno
sabemos que la raíz de 25 5 por lo tanto
la magnitud de este vector o la longitud
de este vector am y lo voy a poner así
la magnitud de este vector a bueno son 5
unidades y eso se notaba también de una
manera muy clara porque tenemos un traer
1 rectángulo
345 la magnitud o la longitud es lo
mismo que 5 unidades
es lo mismo que 5 unidades y bueno si te
das cuenta claramente este no es un
vector unitario porque su magnitud es
distinta de 1 y como un vector unitario
debe de tener una longitud una magnitud
de 1 bueno pues este no es un vector
unitario ahora imagina que queremos
construir un vector voluntario que tenga
la misma dirección que este vector a
pero entonces va a tener que tener una
magnitud de 1 es decir queremos un
vector a me lo voy a poner así este va a
ser un nuevo veto ni vector unitario el
cual quiero que tenga la misma dirección
que este vector a pero que tenga una
magnitud de 1 es decir de una quinta
parte de este vector a una magnitud de
y bueno una forma de encontrarlo es
dividiendo cada una de estas componentes
entre 5 es decir me voy a tomar una
quinta parte de cada una de estas
proponentes y bueno también hay otra
forma de verlo podríamos tomarnos cada
una de estas entradas del vector am y
dividirlas entre la magnitud del vector
es decir dividirlas entre la magnitud
que 5 es más debe ponerlo así y voy a
utilizar la letra o la letra de vector
unitario ok y le voy a poner un gorro
encima y le voy a poner un gorro encima
porque así se denota el vector unitario
así podemos saber que este es un vector
unitario y es más déjeme ponerlo así
este es un vector unitario unitario y
ahora para construir este vector
unitario que tenga la misma dirección
que este vector a y bueno entonces para
encontrarlos lo que vamos a hacer es
tomarnos las componentes de este
rectorado y lo voy a poner es más con
este mismo color
a tomar las dos componentes de esta
rectora pero las voy a dividir entre la
longitud de este vector a es decir me va
a quedar 33 pero a este 3 lo voy a
dividir entre la longitud o la magnitud
de este vector a lo voy a poner si entre
la magnitud de este apertura ok y ahora
me falta la otra componente la otra
componente es 44 y también lo voy a
dividir entre entre la magnitud de este
vector a entre la magnitud de este
vector
y bueno con esto ya tengo un vector
unitario que va en la misma dirección y
entonces que nos quedarían esto es
exactamente lo mismo que tomarme 3 entre
5 3 quintos y lo voy a poner con este
color
es dividido entre 5 ok y la otra
componente
es lo mismo que 4 que 4 dividido entre 5
también entre 5 de lujo
ahora vamos a recorrer tres quintos en
nuestra forma horizontal y cuatro
quintos de forma vertical y si te das
cuenta tiene la misma proporción que
este que tenemos aquí tiene exactamente
la misma proporción y por eso podemos
decir que va en la misma dirección pero
ahora este vector tiene una magnitud de
1 tiene una longitud de 1 y es más es
justo lo que quiero que trabajemos en
este momento así que si nosotros nos
fijamos en la magnitud en la magnitud de
este vector y de este vector y también
le pongo su gorro por aquí ok
esta magnitud es la que yo quiero
averiguar justo ahora bueno pues esto es
lo mismo que la raíz cuadrada que la
raíz cuadrada que la raíz cuadrada ok de
la suma de los cuadrados de cada una de
las componentes
si nosotros elevamos al cuadrado está el
primer componente que me va a quedar 3
al cuadrado es 9 ok
entre 5 al cuadrado lo cual es 25 ok ya
esto le voy a sumar la otra componente
elevada al cuadrado 4 al cuadrado es 16
entre 5 elevado al cuadrado entre 5
elevado al cuadrado lo cual es 25 y
entonces yo me voy a tomar a la suma de
estos dos lo cual es lo mismo que la
raíz cuadrada de 9 16 es 25 es 25 9 más
16 estos dos suman 25 ya esto lo voy a
dividir entre el mínimo común múltiplo
que es 25 es decir me voy a tomar la
raíz cuadrada la raíz cuadrada de 25
entre 25 lo cual es 1 y si ahora me fijo
en la raíz principal o en la raíz
positiva de 1 bueno pues eso es 1 y ya
está
llegamos justo a lo que queríamos tengo
ahora este
y el cual va en la misma dirección que
este vector
tenemos exactamente la misma dirección
pero este es un vector unitario porque
tiene una magnitud de 1 y una magnitud
de 1 y es por eso que tenemos un vector
unitario